hey was someone named Sonya Leeds and
this is Q&A Sunday you're in luck
because this week I'm going to be
answering your property investment
questions so here's how this is going to
go firstly if you enjoy my youtube
channel please smash the like button and
don't forget to subscribe if you're not
already subscribed and turn the
notifications about on so you never miss
a video now last week I put a video out
and there's been so many questions on
last week's video I'm gonna go ahead and
answer your questions from last week
however while I'm answering last week's
questions if you have a question right
now pop up into your head or if you've
got somebody's been bothering you
bugging you giggling at you for a while
around property investment or
entrepreneurship please do comment your
question below in the comments and next
someday guess what's gonna happen that's
right I'm gonna answer your property
investment question next Sunday so let's
see what we've got from last week Jamie
John says hi Samuel I'm about upon my
first student letter HMO however I'm
reluctant to go ahead of it Jeeves the
corona virus as I feel there's a lot of
uncertainty around next year's academic
year and I'm not confident leave all
that out the estate agent has admitted
that the ability to let our properties
at the moment is restricted mainly due
to tenants not being able to view
properties etc do you think I should go
ahead with it your thoughts on this will
be much appreciated thank you Jamie John
obviously I can't give you advice
whether you should or whether you
shouldn't go ahead with this particular
property because I haven't seen it I
don't know the details however what I
will say is if it's a student-led
property and it's near a university
right now universities are people aren't
going to unique because of lockdown but
is that going to be the case what you
need to think of is is that going to be
the case in two three months time when
your property completes is that gonna be
the case next year and the answer is
probably not probably universities are
going to open again because if they
didn't then it would just be absolutely
ridiculous so I probably wouldn't pull
out on the basis that you're not going
to be able to find tenants because I
think that you will in terms of they
value maybe you might want to look at
trying to get a little bit of a bigger
discount just because property prices
are gonna drop a little bit this year I
definitely wouldn't
and if there's a good deal it probably
is still worth going ahead with but I
guess I can't really advise you because
I don't know the property but there's my
general thoughts and I hope that helps
all right what else we've got Frankie
Bolton when going down the lease option
agreement roof how do you calculate the
amount that you'll be paying to the
seller per month you ask the seller what
they're paying per month that's
basically it
I know in your videos you've been saying
that you'll pay their mortgage but how
do you get all the info you ask no
literally you see me on the phone doing
this where I did buy a lot down property
challenge I'm just going to say firstly
you talk to them you make them an offer
and if they say I can't accept that
because I'm a mortgage after huh no
problem I understand what is your
mortgage outstanding you just ask them
the question and if you feel awkward
asking them they all feel awkward
listening and answering you but if you
don't feel awkward asking they won't
feel awkward answering so there before
you start asking personal questions
about their finances you do need to
build a little bit of rapport with them
first create a pattern of asking
questions about the house and then when
they start answering the questions about
the house put forward a tentative it
would offer if they can't because the
mortgage I just ask them the questions
hope that helps good luck my friend what
else we got I get 5% off for rights to
buy my house it is worth five hundred
and sixteen thousand and I can get it
for five hundred thousand is it worth it
nope anything is worth it five percent
discount is not a big deal and if you're
buying a house that's so expensive to
live in as well I would not recommend
doing that I would use that money that
you would have put to buy that house and
I would invest it properly and I would
not buy that five hundred sixty thousand
pound house thumbs down from me Jane
Wong hi Samuel I would like to ask in
case I lose my full-time job in the near
future is there any chance to get a buy
to let mortgage so if you're trying to
get a buy to let mortgage your job isn't
as important as it is if you're getting
your residential mortgage if you want if
you're getting a if you're buying a
house to live in the mortgage companies
really care about what your income is
and how much you're earning if you're
buying a house to rent out they care
about the house more than they care
about you so your income doesn't have to
be high so if you lose your job
I mean honestly I've known people that
I've got buy-to-let mortgages and they
from self-employment has been like 5
grams a year and they've got buy-to-let
mortgages no problem so I'm not
qualified to give mortgage advice but my
suggestion Jane will be to speak to a
mortgage broker find out the situation
but ultimately you have no control
necessarily on whether you're going to
lose your job or not so I won't worry
about it too much but definitely speak
to a mortgage broker
hope that helps what else we got drew
drew loves gaming awesome I Samuel I
love your content and your true
inspiration thank you very much
is there geographical locations where
Lease Option agreements work best and
why yeah there is lease option
agreements only work on properties where
the property owner does not need or
can't get the money now that could be an
inherited property that could be a tired
landlord or very likely a proposition
negative equity and areas geographical
locations where properties are in
negative equity or areas where the
property market has dipped and it's not
recovered so right now in the north of
England there's a lot of areas like that
such as Bradford Middlesbrough Newcastle
Sunderland these areas have all still
got lots of properties in negative
equity so you'll find a lot of people
wanting to do Lease Option agreements
there if the property market dips just
generally across the UK it's going to
lead a lot of people in negative equity
especially because of buy a holiday
mortgage period that's happened people's
mortgages have got a little bit bigger
and then house price is dropping there
is going to be more negative equity
properties which means there's going to
be more opportunity the lease option
agreements across the board hopefully
very soon okay how's that helped if you
did comment below if you guys are
enjoying the video don't forget to smash
the like button leave a nice comment
don't forget as well if you have a
question
there's popping up even if it's a
question it's an offshoot of one of
these questions just comment it below
and I'll do my best to answer your
question next Sunday at 7 p.m. okay W J
wooda CH J wooded I'm about to buy my
first property investment with the view
to refinance on a bye to layer in
September time how do you think the
lenders valuations
will be impacted by covert so the
property listen because of covert
property prices are going to drop a
little bit
so what I'll say is if you're doing a
buy and then you're planning to refer
them with Finance in September time just
make sure that you've got a number
you've got plenty cushion so it is gonna
be possibly download a little bit so
just make sure you've got cushion
maybe renegotiate you say you're about
to buy your first property investment
maybe renegotiate it a little bit lower
also make sure that your builders quotes
are absolutely legit itemized breakdown
so because if you're if you're billed as
a quote goes high and then your
valuation comes low then that's when
things can get a little bit sketchy
especially if you've had to borrow the
money from aunties and uncles in the
first place and then you can't refinance
what you hope for
however banks are lending mortgages are
still lending right now they're not
right this second very much because they
can't get into the houses but I can't
still have any issues refinancing
because the banks have got lots of money
and mortgages are going ahead as normal
so that's that's that again like I don't
know for a hundred percent I don't know
the property but that's the general
overview of what's happening right now
with that strategy and I hope you found
that useful what else we got Roger
Rodrigue I know this guy I love you
Roger I hope you while he says do you
think section 24 be scrapped in light of
everything going on I hope so I mean I
don't know I'm not holding my breath but
I'll happily sign a petition maybe I
should head one up
section 24 does bogum a is I think it's
nothing it's a terrible rule and this is
basically affects landlords if they own
their properties in their personal name
which I do have a lot of properties in
my personal name it's not worth if
you've got properties in your personal
name it's not worth the stamp duty
transferring them to a limited company
it's not worth it you're better off to
just keep them in your personal name and
if you've got properties in your
personal name section 24 is a bit of a
tax nightmare so I hope it will be
scrapped in light of everything that's
going on
who knows let's see if let's see if the
government do the right thing maybe well
maybe we should do a petition okay next
I am Sam Fowler great to meet you Sam
Fowler how you doing I'm in the post to
buy my first property investment to live
in Awful's accept it before this
pandemic in your opinion is it a bad
time to Bart I'm back at my parents
after five years renting and if I don't
buy now I'll have to rent again haven't
signed on the dotted line yet as I don't
know if I should go ahead or not thank
you for any advice Sam Fowler
if I'm really honest I wouldn't but girl
wouldn't go ahead
continue renting and the money that you
were going to put down to buy a property
to live in I wouldn't sign I'd pull out
I'd take on the chin any cost that
you've already incurred and I would use
that money to invest in property smart
wise in light of the situation that's
what I would do I rent this house that I
live in I live in a beautiful house I
rent it you don't have to buy a house to
live in especially in this time the
worst climate you do that right now all
of the things I've been teaching for the
last 2 3 4 5 years I've driven now than
ever before so when I used to say things
like don't put your money in the bank
because of you because of because of
deeper depreciation that couldn't be
true right now because they're printing
money when I said rent where you live
couldn't be true right now so that's my
advice
ok next lorraine nixon samuel went to
own must be a fab strategy now would you
agree yeah I'd agree oh what a great all
right Reese nebs with lease options when
you say you take over the mortgage does
that mean you have to get one off the
bank or is the mortgage still in the
vendors name but you give them the money
to cover it the month those mortgage
remains in the sellers name so you take
on their existing mortgage which means
that you don't have to apply for a new
mortgage which means that if you've got
bad credit or no credit it doesn't
matter cuz you'll just babysit in their
mortgage but it's remaining in their
name and you're gonna pay the mortgage
company direct or you're gonna pay the
seller and then they're gonna pay the
mortgage company and then you're gonna
ask for quarterly statements to make
sure that the mortgage is getting paid
because ultimately you have an interest
in this house even though you haven't at
all deeds hope that helps
boom shocka okay just one or two more
questions leave it out UK says why not
wait for the crash everybody using the
holiday mortgage will feel it in three
months time the lockdown will be going
on until the vaccine
what about all the tenants not paying
rent people this is a bad time to invest
save all your happy is listen I would
have to disagree with you because I
think that once you've got what some of
what you're saying is is true I don't
agree with your with your conclusion
especially if you're smart if you don't
know what you're doing then maybe it
would be a bad time to invest because
you buy now property prices are going to
go down however the problem that we've
seen I'm just gonna wait for this crash
I'm gonna wait for this crash is what
normally happens is people that are
waiting waiting waiting waiting as it's
crushing crushing crushing crushing and
then you only realize when it starts
going up again and normally when it goes
up it shoots so the mindset of what what
what you're saying right now and and
listen you know you do what you want to
do I'm just get all I can give you is my
opinion and I've been I've been
investing in property now for over a
decade I've seen the recession of 2008
crashed I was buying at that time I
started buying in 2009 crash - that's
tonight at the just jerk it reminds me
of when I started investing what you're
saying right now that's what everyone
was saying so I get it a lot of people
think like this but the problem is when
private property prices are going down
you want to be buying as they're going
down and you want to be saying look
they're going down and using that oh
I'll screenshot you what you just said
and I'll use that as an excuse to get
really cheap properties I'll say this is
what people are saying this is if the
newspapers say this I'm people the
newspapers are saying it's a bad time to
invest I'm like yes and I'll use that
newspaper clipping all use comments like
this to then get really good deals below
market value and then property projects
might go down a little bit more but then
what happens is this you up and what
happens is people like you that are
saying no no no wait and save your
pennies wait and save your pennies
you'll be working really hard in your
job you'll be saving up your pennies
best you possibly can and then slowly
prices shoo and then you miss there and
then you've got a few thousand in you
back that you've been working really
hard at you are wait for next and this
is exactly what most people do most
people just work really really hard in
their jobs save their pennies save their
pennies while they're printing money in
the
becoming worthless and then suddenly
things happen in the and then what in
meanwhile people over here we're just
making making the most of the situation
and getting rich so I would entirely
disagree however what I would agree is
that property prices are gonna go down
so as long as you're aware that that's
gonna happen throughout this year and
you buy for the long term and you
followed golden the golden rules which
is buying below market value buying for
cashflow purposes not capital
appreciation and pushing up the value of
property prices but pushing up the value
of your property known how to push the
value up right it's very very good time
so that's my opinion and let me know
what you think though guys comment below
last question
ends fizzy says how do you find the true
market value of a property without using
Mouse price okay you I would always use
Mouse price but you just look at what's
selling in the street look at what's
sold see what's selling see what's sold
I even on Rightmove you can look at this
house prices sold house prices see
what's actually selling in the street
see what's sold in the street over the
last three years within quarter mile of
the house and start doing light for lie
comparable that's just exactly what the
value was doing guess what you have the
same software so guys hope you found
this useful this is Q&A Sunday comment
your questions below smash the like
button it will help the algorithm so
more people will see the videos and also
if you commented below as you should
have done don't forget to subscribe and
turn the notification belt on because if
it's not then I might answer your
question next and then you won't even
know I answered your question you even
know address cue so subscribe turn the
notifications bell on
thanks so much I'll see you next time
[Music]